but the time is fast approaching for me
to step down because I'm not well or I'm
fit for office but because of you ready
that's John Lithgow playing British
Prime Minister Winston Churchill in the
Netflix series the crown the role earned
lift go and emmy award his storied
on-screen careers all's also includes
two oscar-nominated performances in the
movies terms of endearment and the world
according to GARP he also has three more
Emmys for the hit TV comedy third Rock
from the Sun oh I love that show
let's go first made a name for himself
in theatres he returns to the stage in
his latest one-man Broadway show it's
called stories by heart
let's go shares deeply personal moments
and tales from the same book the same
book that his stage producer father read
to him while he was growing up those
memories still resonate years later when
we were kids my father told us bedtime
stories he read them to us from this
book we would pick the stories and he
would read them out loud performing all
the parts full out when I hold it in my
hands now my father comes back he really
does John Lithgow joins us now welcome
back to the table buddy back you get
everybody's attention right away because
you walk out on the stage and you say
what hey what the hell is it prax
everybody up and the lights are still on
and I thought are the lights going down
but you leave the lights up on purpose
in the very beginning yes it's a
different kind of show and it's so nice
that the two of you have seen it Nora
you're invited because it's very hard to
describe to people what it is it's a
very personal reminiscence it's a
conversation but the audience which is
why we leave the house lights up for a
few minutes it's a love letter to your
father because of you to your dad and
then it's about them to a performance
and it's about storytelling it's about
it's a BA about why we all gathered
together to listening to stories and
some of us have the urge and the need to
tell them and that redemptive power of
that those stories which your father
told you and then you tell him as he's
ailing when you're doing this all by
yourself out there alone is your father
with you or does he arrive every now and
again or is are you just in the mode and
you're acting well in a sense he's
always with me a little bit I'm sure I'm
very much like him genetics has
something to do with that he is the
reason I'm an actor I mean he was a man
of the theater I didn't really want to
become an actor I didn't want to go into
the family business what did you want to
do I was interested in being a painter I
was much more interested in that but you
know eventually applause asserted itself
yeah and and I have just in so many ways
I followed the trajectory of his life as
a lot of sons do this is the first time
I've ever written something created
something for myself to perform for
other people tapping on my own
experience of life and I find that the
thing that fascinates me is what is it
why do we all want need and love stories
I'm fascinated on because it's such a
bare-bones stage it's just you in a
couple of chairs and a table and a water
in a book but you make the most amazing
sounds would you do that that how you do
the clipping of the barber things and
that that maniacal laugh yes you just
show that one of the stories is wring
Gardner's hairs haircut uh-huh which
every word of the story is told by a
barber as he's giving an old-time
shaving a haircut to his customer his
silent customer a stranger in town and
at a certain point I start the haircut
you know and I do all those incredibly
complicated with your mouth that oh yes
and and that laughs that maniacal laugh
you made the audience laugh when you did
the laugh
yes the very interesting thing about
that story is it starts out
light-hearted yeah ends up
they're dark and the quality of his
laughter doesn't really change but your
response to it curdles before your eyes
by the end do you feel like there's a
body in the basement the other story you
tell is a PG Wodehouse story in which
it's a wonderful crazy wood house living
room scene you change about between so
many different British accents how do
you do that so many different people
it's pure technique what can I say John
it's I don't know it's the essence of
storytelling it's a kind of act of the
imagination the whole evening is about
imagination not so much mine as the
imagination of the audience my challenge
is to create a world right up there on
stage with make everybody see things
that aren't there make everybody see the
difference between 1 2 3 4 5 characters
on stage at the same time including a
parrot who has one of the best lines you
know story say congratulations to you
for your sixth Emmy 204 portray Winston
Churchill and in the crown and the
second seasons done the third season
replaced the characters will the actors
I should say playing the characters what
do you think of that well it was always
part of the deal that was their scheme
Claire and Matt and Vanessa they all
knew that they would do two seasons and
then they'd be replaced you talk about
an act of the imagination
they just presume that the audience will
follow and they'll be glad that there's
an age-appropriate Queen Elizabeth do
you think it's ingenious I think it's a
genius and along comes Olivia Colman was
one of the great British actress to
replace Claire Claire was very honoured
yeah glad you didn't follow your
painting plans and so good to see you
could you take us off with that maniacal
laugh that you do well mainly he kind of
whinnies great to have you here
stories by heart is on Broadway through
March 4th